hello believe nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all the major problems of the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn seven ways to
crush it in your niche on social media
and as always guys if you're listening
if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
the counter below put quotes around it
to other people can be inspired as well
and when you write it down it's much
more likely to stick with yourself to
enjoy so because of the success that
I've had on social media I often get
asked by people who want to get their
channels going and started how do I have
more success on my channels how do I get
more impact more influence help reach my
goals what's your advice on what I
should be doing until today I'm going to
share my seven ways seven techniques for
you to crash it in your niche on social
media we number one is you have to find
the right platform find the best
platform for you and it starts with
combining two things one is what are
your skills what are you really good at
what do you enjoy doing what do you want
to get better at so do you like being in
front of the camera like I do would you
rather do podcast and just do audio only
would you rather write and you can't
stay in the side of being in front of a
camera
what are your word of your skills line
up and the content that you're going to
share are you a graphic designer you
want to create beautiful images are you
a videographer you want to be behind the
camera editing great things what are the
skills that you have and combine it with
where are your customers so for me I
love YouTube because I get to be in
front of the camera it's where I have
the most skills I'd much rather make a
video than I would write a blog post and
I go to youtube because it's where most
of my audience is my audience are
entrepreneurs or budding entrepreneurs
or wannabe entrepreneurs and a lot of
you guys are on YouTube and you're
watching it so that combination works
really really really well for me it's
why I've invested so much of my time
into YouTube as opposed to the other
platforms and so understanding one what
you're really good at where your passion
lies what skills you have with to where
is your tired
market where is your audience and then
what platform which social media
platform performs the best across those
two things and I wouldn't try to do
every single social media platform to
start because this is what happens
entrepreneurs try to do everything and
then you end up doing nothing well and
you're posting cracks to all of these
different places so pick the one start
there but the one that has the best
results the best potential results for
you and go all in on that one to start
with number two is just start a lot of
people just don't start you have an idea
one day I'm going to start a YouTube
channel I have this big vision for what
I want to do but you don't actually do
anything and this is where your
perfectionism can be a problem a lot of
people they don't want to start until
it's perfect I need to have the perfect
channel arm to have the perfect setup
and need the perfect year be the perfect
logo I need the perfect name all of this
stuff has to be perfect and because you
want it to be perfect you don't do
anything you never actually take any
action you just live in your head of
this future thing that you want to do
and so if you want to do it just start
start expected to be crap it's okay
because nobody's paying attention to you
yet you're just getting started you
don't have a ton of followers that
you're going to mess up with just start
and make it better the next day and
better the next day and better the next
day as soon as you get any kind of idea
the best thing you can do is take some
kind of immediate action towards
achieving your goal whether it's social
media or any other kind of goal
immediate action you get an idea just
start do something immediately right
away right now it's a social media
platform that you're interested in you
want to start a YouTube channel started
go to YouTube create your account and
record a video today expecting to be
terrible expecting to be garbage that's
okay it's your first video just make
tomorrow's better just start number
three is model success anytime you don't
know how to do something the best thing
you do is look for somebody who's really
accomplished what you want to do and
look at the steps that they took and you
can look at where they're at now you can
also look at their journey and the path
that they took and learn from them so
for YouTube as an example there's a
number of people that I look up to that
I've learned from I love watching Gary
Vaynerchuk channel I love
watching those houses channel there's
number of other channels that I look up
to I learned a ton from Tim Schmoyer
zero leaves on how to build a proper
YouTube channel the right thing to do
and strategies and so I'd be constantly
looking for people that I can learn from
in your industry so if you want to be
big on YouTube you're going to be big on
Instagram or big on Twitter or big on
LinkedIn look at the people who are
already crushing it understand their
path break it down go back on their
history and their timeline and try to do
a research to understand what were the
things that they did to achieve the
success and what I love looking at most
is what was the turning point for them
what was the breaking point that turned
them from just somebody who's doing okay
to really crushing it and if you look at
that for a lot of different people in
your field you'll get enough of an idea
what you need to do to be successful tip
number four is be a storyteller
the reason you want to be a storyteller
is so that people can relate to you on a
human level when they do that it's not
the product anymore that it's about but
the story behind it and what that means
is that they're more inclined to follow
you on social media to purchase your
products and to promote it to their
friends because they identify with you
so for example me personally I am on
snapchat I am on Instagram I am on
Facebook whenever I do post it's not
just a matter of me saying hey guys here
are the prices for all the classes
coming up hey guys here is a brand new
social you should come out and then I
let clients customers and friends make
sure that they can see the
behind-the-scenes of what I do day to
day which helps them relate to me which
helps them bond with me and ultimately
gives more valid than just the thing
that we offer at the school as a result
people are reaching out and joining our
school when they've never even heard of
it except through the social media where
they watch the snaps or they watch the
Instagram posts or where they're on
Facebook ultimately there are a lot of
ways to reach your clients but all
together you want to make sure that
again you're a storyteller and you're
not just promoting the products or niche
that you're in
[Music]
tip number five is do collapse
one of the fastest way to grow your
presence and audience in a niche is to
do collaborations people who are already
in your niche serving the same audience
now they may not be exact competitors of
yours because you have your message they
have theirs but if you're targeting the
same people and you can provide some
kind of value to them then it's a great
opportunity for you to be able to build
up your influence in your network one of
the first people I did a collaboration
with with Tim Schmoyer he has a channel
for video creators and again I mentioned
I love that channel I use it a lot to
learn how to build up my channel and I
was a big fan of what he did and I
reached out and we connect and I said
hey I'd love to be a part of your
channel here are some ideas that I could
present that I think would be of
interest to you and really provide some
value to your audience and we picked one
and that was the first piece of content
that that went up and it was great
because Tim's audience is entrepreneurs
but Tim will teach people how to build a
YouTube channel and I'll teach people
how to be entrepreneurs and so I'm not
sharing the exact same advice that Tim
is and so I went on his channel he
eventually came on my channel I think
I've done three or more collabs on Tim's
channel I just came back from Clymer
Khan in Palm Springs met other youtubers
ended up doing four or five different
collaborations on different people's
channels so if you're reaching out to do
collaborations the ideal people are the
ones that you already know of you've
already consumed their content you know
what message is going to hit for them
you're a fan of their channel you engage
in their channel ideally you want to be
a known quantity right you've left
comments on their videos you've engaged
with them on Twitter you connected
somehow and a little bit of a back and
forth so that when you reach out and say
hey I'd love to do a collaboration here
are some ideas I have they already know
who you are because not maybe all the
great content you put up because maybe
you're just getting started but because
of the interaction that you have already
made with them and that's easy to do
it's just providing value on what
they're already doing so if they're big
on Twitter respond to them on Twitter if
they're big on YouTube make a comment on
every single video you should be a known
quantity to them before you reach out to
make a collaboration but once you do
corporations are one of the best ways to
would quickly grow an audience
[Music]
tip number six is build a team
I said start you got to do everything
yourself I'm a big believer in not
spending money until you're making money
so I do everything myself when I first
started this YouTube channel I did
everything I was in front of the camera
I was behind the camera was editing I
was researching I was doing the SEO I
was doing everything for my channel and
because of that I was doing a video a
month - a video a week that was a max
that I could do as I started earning
some more money but okay I'm getting
serious about this I want to start to
build a team and the first person I
hired was somebody to do my editing
because I hated it I was super slow at
it and that allowed me to go for a video
week - a video a day just hiring
somebody to do the editing for me I got
to spend more time doing what I love he
was way better doing the editing anyway
and my channel started to lift and grow
now I've got eight people who work on my
YouTube channel and it allows me to make
three videos a day right and so because
of the people that I've surrounded
myself with I'm able to put out more
content and I'm able to spend my time
doing what I think I'm great at and not
worrying about everything else that
associated with building up my channel
and so at the start you start at the
start you do everything yourself you
can't compare yourself to where somebody
else is that in their middle so you
start at the start you do everything
yourself
but quickly start to think about what is
it that you are great at and where you
want to spend your time at and as soon
as you start making some money on the
channel and any social media channel
that you're working on start to think
about okay as soon as I start making
some money this is the first person I'm
going to hire start thinking immediately
that you're planning to hire people to
turn this into a business to allow you
to focus on what you are great at and
tip number seven their problem my most
important tip is be consistent so many
of you guys are not consistent enough to
have success it's a real problem you
know if you look at my channel why is my
youtube channel grown so much I've made
over five thousand videos only four
thousand of them are public we've got a
thousand non-public just practice videos
that I put up on my channel five
thousand videos I
very good at the start if you go back to
my channel look at my earlier videos
you'll see that I wasn't very good I
wasn't very comfortable I was nervous I
was stuttering I'll try to find my path
it wasn't very good and with more
practice and as I did more I got better
and it also trains the audience people
come when they expect to get more
content and it plays well with the
YouTube algorithm or whatever algorithm
you're posting to in social media you
need to be consistent and so so many
people start and they make one video or
they make one piece of content and
that's it and they fall off and the next
we can able to make one more and then
they fall back down next week you got to
put in your calendar if you want to
crush it in anything that you do right
the topic how we're going to crush you
in social media you want to crush it in
anything that you view you have to spend
the time you got to dedicate the time to
make it great yes there are shortcuts
yes you can model success yes you can
get there faster but you still have to
spend the time not just going to happen
you're going to turn on the camera and
just be amazing and get five million
subscribers right you got to be
consistent and so look at your calendar
and factoring the time either every day
or big chunk of time every week to spend
on your social media creating better
content and I'm a firm believer that the
quantity leads to the quality the
quality is what's going to get you the
base the subscribers the brand deals the
attention the impact the quality content
was to get to the quality you have to
produce a ton of quantity just like
anything else to get the muscles you
have to lift a lot of weights to get
good at the language you have to
practice over and over and over again
the quantity leads to the quality and so
you need to be consistent in your output
those are my seven tips on what to do to
crush it in your niche on social media
I'd love to know what did you guys think
what was your favorite rule is there an
8 9 10 that you want to add to the list
leave it down in the comments below
super curious find out I made this video
because Brett Vaughn asked me to so if
there's a topic you'd like me to cover
in a future seven ways video check out
the link in the description and cast
your vote I also want to give a quick
shout out to Vincent Montello
Vincent thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book you're one word and
doing the review on your YouTube channel
I really really really appreciate it man
and I hope you're enjoying the read so
thank you guys for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon